welcome to this video against dork 2004
let's see got any name or something no
pretty fresh account and all three
minute rating of 1400 but 2205 okay and
it's hope that is a legit game this kind
of thing is always a bit irritating
yeah you kind of hear the turning pages
of this opening book that is now getting
from his shelf what is happening now 3c
four or 3g three on Bishop g5 or III or
g3 it is okay yes okay sorry guys just
making a little bit of fun iam it's a
some fist is taking his time right okay
d 5v5 it looks a bit strange I agree if
you say so but it does prevent White's
main idea playing c4 and therefore it
has some some merit this approach only
drawback is of course i'm playing a ton
of pawn moves and this can be a problem
certainly don't think so much here maybe
what is he up to 2 c1 to play does you
want to play you for maybe you form yeah
my development is not great as mentioned
champa should be seven look scary queen
bee three might be a move on a five or
so no it just develops okay hmm just
knight c6 I guess right there what I
need to if I manage to complete my
development here without any serious
accidents then I'm okay that is clear I
mean he and Bishop c5 that should should
be some should be okay right it's
nothing nothing great but it should be
okay maybe I can get here I can go here
and get in a hive too and now he's
playing really quickly we played them in
a very slow manner and now he's sped up
enormously okay I have to go to a 6 this
is wed belongs anyway okay what is the
point here don't quite get it
hmm
I mean I can kick this rock out with a
98 for example I'm just not not sure
what to do I can also play rook c8
getting one pair of rooks off yeah okay
I'm doing that I'm kind of unsure if I
should do that but let's get rid of one
pair of rooks okay chicks Bishop takes
huh I don't expect a single move that is
playing absolutely not a single one yeah
if I was thinking I should be really
okay rook c8 is now almost unavoidable
so Luke CA idea the doubling is harmless
on f6 I mean it it's not any any kind of
problem okay so i can take here take a
four but he might invade okay i can
start with taking this that's definitely
not bad and now queen a form hmm he's
got Quinn to c7 is this how dangerous is
that I always have Bishop to f8 back so
I really don't see what the point is
okay I can also play Queen c7 Queen g7
there is also nothing special happening
okay it's not even trying to invade so
let's go back or do I have an active
move not going back need to make sure
that i'm not losing on time ultimately
threatening f6 now
yeah f6 how does the untangle has his
pieces yep ok so f6 Bishop f4 is not
leading to that much but I can go here
I'd and just simplifying stuff let's
simplify takes just queen takes for
Knight f6 Queen before just trying to
get to a technical phase of the game now
here that's good for the for the pin on
the fourth-ranked make this somewhat
awkward for him so you five right not
okay i can play age six that's actually
but the night is hanging why don't I
take the night yeah and now he even has
this this completely this opportunity
that wasn't even there I am awkward
awkward awkward it's really crazy
sometimes
check time morning check how am I going
to play that Queenie 8 is a move which
is kind of kind of awkward once you
cover everything Bishop to c4 and then
push the pawns 42 seconds okay check
k how do I win actually I don't don't
see it at the moment don't see a super
clear plan the ship the bishop and ce4
is not ideally placed really should
somehow be on the Kings side and now i
might get this in which up to here to e
form check
check check okay so i'm king at the
whole endgame check this makes things a
little bit easier fortunately check
check check mate Wow whoo yeah don't
know I mean it of course I can just take
the naija at one point hmm okay I really
played a risky opening here which is
very ambitious yet it wants to get a
good structure which I got but it
neglects development quite a bit and
somewhere around here okay I could have
played a six but this this looks this
looks kind of okay now this this
shouldn't shouldn't be too bad really
will be three a-five that looks on
normal Bishop here in the rook c8 to
trade yeah I was really thinking he
should take on c8 get my bishop back
there the same the service was a bit
surprising turn that really surprised me
that that he allowed me to just simply
play this kind of business or Knight g4
was interesting already but okay rook c8
is quite logical yeah and I can just
grab him hmm there is no counter play I
was still expecting this but yeah the
computer has merciless with 97 I
wouldn't have played that move I would
have played probably queen here chance
this kind of thing it's a bit passive
but secure
yet here I'm really just a power nap
suppose this was good i think you know
age six also good with this is a good
movie i can just take the could shake
the naija that's silly it's really silly
i saw it right after the move of course
it's it's still it's still winning but
it wasn't really necessary and here by
the way queen g5 is a good check it's a
good move far simpler move actually that
gets into completely completely winning
endgame this pawn is even promoting yeah
okay i think it was a decent game i
should have taken the night but other
than that it was quite ok ok well thanks
for watching